[Music]
in sued the sole news that's why I need
like a chicken noodle soup submitted by
a hello panda oh that's a snack that's
that chocolate we have it we have it
it's called hello panda right yeah it's
so rich yes okay
London things classical music can help
tone down crime really yeah cuz they'll
be barred i buy this actually I heard of
a study where they played rock and roll
like are like heavy metal music for rats
and they were way more violent with each
other than rats they played classical
music with plants too yeah I was just
thinking with plants yes I don't believe
in plants though I like the rats exam
you don't believe in plants you alter
closer to us
cuz the plants would know what are they
gonna do you can't really base the study
off of plants and then go okay this
applies to humans stress that living
things fill Oh fuel so you should stop
letting those guys play heavy metal a
barbell do you don't play heavy metal
how do they do this we play in the
loudspeaker like then you go to my Rodeo
Drive or whatever oh yeah and then they
have the speakers on the lap oh okay so
every everywhere it makes sense because
music is just human intent made
beautifully and if you listen to like
something that's made from human energy
that's like anger like heavy metal it's
about that but what if it's a love song
but heavy metal I think it's a vibration
because we pick up on vibrations like
constantly they're just invisible then
there's always energy going through the
air and I feel like angry vibrations are
different frequencies then the like
calming vibration this week at a spa
about like I think that's like super
it's not aggressive really like and
that's not you maybe you better have
drugs too like I'm the demon about
actually enjoy a lotta night you're on
dress I listen to it when I'm trying to
like focus and like study the articles
for jakie news and I just put my eating
in EDM and I'm like depends on what kind
you also have to remember classical was
heavy metal at one point to them that's
Truman you know like they have different
movements so there are moving like
Mozart's grandpa's like turn that [ __ ]
off
yeah you and you forgive young people
music [ __ ] crazy ass no but did they
have different movements there's some of
more faster and more slower so they do
have aggressive intent portions of
classical music - yeah they do like
angry piano playing I disagree bark of
any variable with you that's what Jesus
s Oh Scotland Yard is planning to pump
classical music into this North London
housing project but they call it like in
the state so this is like a notorious
estate called Broadwater Farm aka the
farm and so apparently ever since back
the 80s it was like a riot that happened
there and then just ever since then like
the residents there and the police
they've been clashing a lot and so it's
really violent in that area they're
saying that back in 2003 they first
tried this whole classical music thing
in a tube station that had a game
problem and so they're saying that after
the music have been playing that the
robberies had dropped 33% that's a lot
yeah that cuz gangs don't like classical
music they're like where's the hip-hop
and then they run away it's weird though
because like serial killers and like
American Psycho where he just kills
people the classical music but they do
it like really calmly I think that's
when Creon some heist movies they do a
heist to classical music explain that
one to me thank you
it's just they don't do it aggressively
they do it very smoothly it calms like
slow slides through the bit through the
building or whatever so you think the
robberies went down but the heists and
murders went up you see those members
sophisticated crime yeah sophisticated
see we need the full data we can't just
look at things in a vacuum petty crime
is gone but now the high-level heists
are back multi-layered high yeah more
museums are being wrong yeah art thieves
sophisticated can I just admit that I
actually really love that [ __ ] when I
read about that like oh like a [ __ ] a
museum just got robbed and like all this
really crazy art just got taken I'm like
that so [ __ ] cool hey I get sick too
imagine all that its social
sophisticated slowly cut the glass or I
don't know what the hell they don't know
why they do and then they rappel down
and [ __ ] he's a plunger all that [ __ ]
dude but then by the way they cut up a
whole like our arm weight within a knot
and then how they get in I think you
talk about cartoons dude yeah no I've
seen it all Ocean's eleven it's true
they have a whole team yeah that's what
I was thinking yeah and you gotta have
like oh he memorized the laser you gotta
have a circus friend yeah you got to
have a nerd friend you're gonna have a
black guy and they all could be
ethnically diverse Asian guy who's like
I'm not that short
yeah
the complex solving of problems yeah the
Asian guy's always a nerd or yeah or
they want to be like edgy and different
so then the Asian guy won't be the nerd
stuff maybe you'll be like somebody else
like the Mexican guy or whatever yeah
yeah and it's just everything's opposite
there's a computer nerd guy always it
sounds like [ __ ] fast and furious cut
it out
it's or Ocean's eleven no buts that
one's the asian guy is the asian the
aging that was the stereo
that's true was he no use a Chinese
circus no see that's what I'm saying see
oceans it was it was Jet Li wasn't it
gently and Ocean's eleven wow that's the
most racist [ __ ] out there wasn't it mr.
Miyagi no well was it lo pan from big
trouble is he also from the Goonies oh
yeah yeah probably somebody delageteau
Tim's been in so many movies good so now
I gonna see of pumping classical music
right it's gonna work in that particular
project there's like 5,000 residents
there how come they only have two
choices just classical and what about uh
sure
there's leave us wrap yeah army yeah
whatever just got some wingman dollars
oh yeah we don't want anyone like just
making love sweet passionate love on
there in the tree that'll increase a lot
of the you know the idea of the new
constable in charge of law and order I
mean they should get it should mix it up
you know they should mix it up like the
least crime associated music you know
like they got polka Wednesday's speakers
long Jam slow jams on Thursdays like 90s
R&B yeah nineties and Fridays the stoner
music can't commit crimes to like
sublime reggae well sublime has a song
of them right yeah yeah you know like
that side of yeah so we'll have beach
reggae on Friday okay my goodness now
Saturday how about a little bit of like
a DS Bon Jovi
I like that I could somehow hack this
system and I'm like let's let's start
some crimes
and I upload like heavy metal music and
then people start fighting you
dude you look like a hacker thank you
you would be the hacker he did that and
I was like I believe right I could do
that is a hold on about to start some
crimes got an extra not kidding he got
an extra loud keyboard with his computer
he ordered it separately and it's like
the loud you're sick yeah he's like my
it's like one sentence yeah I did three
sounds busier than he is and you push
the button yeah he has a sound effect on
this phone what yeah you dude
did you look for extra loud type
typewriter
no I was with my brother and that
confused or and we we were and he was
like you want the click Keys and I was
like I can't film while he's doing it
I'll use typing things whatever dude she
keeps me I want you still won anyway
yeah I do cuz you're loud ask type oh
right that's why yeah that's why she
doesn't want anyone to hear in your
throat well that's true too but like
that's the main like it's also because I
don't want this in my video whatever you
just shoot loads over there every day
all day every day the mood of the house
it's alive the house is alive there's
people right it's just like I won't
catch it cuz I'm so used to it's like
ambience noise zombie noise yeah just
like that's fine you know I hear from
other rooms I always you're like such a
good boy
[Laughter]
she talks forgets - you think you like a
little person you're not and like me I'm
not even then close to being in there
she's talking to okay you don't talk to
use to talk to an animal yeah
that's not true
I won't talk to them I have long
conversations with my dogs
I don't talk to anything they can't look
you mean and I and talk to me bad that's
not true it's about respect yeah what is
it you talk to babies I do not talk to
baby nothing that's good
babies I like it when I don't talk back
yeah I won't talk to your baby or your
babies night I mean my baby's not gonna
be around you so that's all yeah well
we'll see but there you you're gonna pop
I did not say congratulations to you I
never gave you my address on purpose oh
well mean I'll find it pretty easy my
buddy Joe I'll give it to us thank you
what the code nori but I'll see you over
there just bring food then and fine okay
what do you want i pizza all right bring
your loud keyboard [ __ ] bunny throw
whatever it is I hope you guys enjoyed
this video for more please subscribe to
our Channel and you could check out the
last video right here
[Music]